hey everybody its Jesse and I hope you
all had a good good weekend today we're
gonna keep working on our server
jas file so last week we with the least
at the end of last week we got our file
uploads working and we also got the
emails working with SendGrid so the next
step is to send data to our project
management system which is rike through
their API so they have if you want to
check out what I'm gonna be looking at
on my other screen reich has
documentation so it's developers dot
right calm so i'm gonna paste that in
the live chat just in case anybody's
interested in checking it out
hey Sebastian's back in the live chat
good to have you back how you then
all right I'm just a sure if you see
something like this this is the
documentation that I'm that I'm going
from so Reich has a REST API I've
already set up all this stuff so we have
the API key in the dot n file so you all
of course won't have the API key
but so what this obviously is not gonna
work for you if you try to run this but
that's what I'll be working with I'm not
sure if there's a free plan on Reich or
not yeah I really don't know so I'm not
sure if he'd be able to sign up for a
free account to test it out
all right cool so last week Sebastian
was working a concert and said 12 hours
a day standing in the Sun so yeah cool
now you can hang out inside and watch
computer screen back to normal huh hey
how's it going everybody oh cool uh
Sean's back - awesome alright so this is
gonna be a short stream today because I
have a meeting at 3 p.m. Eastern Time so
that is in less than an hour so I was
kind of hoping that I wouldn't have a
meeting I have kind of a standing
meeting every Monday at 3 p.m. but it
often gets canceled or postponed and
things so I was hoping that would happen
today but it didn't so probably we're
gonna do maybe like one Pomodoro cycle
of coding and then some questions and
question answer stuff and then I'll be
done so this would be way shorter than
normal but with more within the range
that I always kind of shoot for which is
less than an hour I never seem to
accomplish that so I'm not gonna go over
any of the code that's this change of
the pull requests so I think we had four
pull requests over the weekend all from
Kevin so thank you so much Kevin you can
check out if you go to the repo and you
go on a pull request look at the clothes
request and the the last four so it'll
be I think the last one was number 30 so
just look at the last four and you can
check it out so you'll see the only
thing that I'm going to point out
because it may be helpful is we have an
example file now for a dot n so
obviously the normal dot n file is not
going to be saved because that's where
all the API keys are so we don't want to
share those so this is here just to let
you know what should be in that
just give you some examples and I'll
have to add to this because I've added a
few things in which obviously Kevin
couldn't see because it was in my end
file so that might be useful just so you
can see how it how it should be set up
this is actually much more orderly than
mine okay and I have my I actually have
my end file open on my other screen to
make sure that I don't accidentally look
at it and then have to go change all my
keys but we'll be working today mainly
just in server jazz yeah I don't think
we have to do anything in the service
request j/s file so I'm gonna move this
over bed make this bigger I'm even gonna
hide that since we won't need it so let
me show you what I've been working on
really not having done much this morning
I caught up on checking out the pull
request merging them emails it's kind of
a sluggish morning I still feel a bit
sluggish I'm not sure I hope I'm not
getting sick or anything I just have
haven't been able to shake off just
sleepiness from this morning but so
here's what I've done I've made well in
my dot and file I've I've put I think
all the things that I'll need to get the
right API working so the URL that I need
to hit the API key and then some IDs for
for people that we have in the system so
I I want the way the right API works is
anything that happening that I do
through the API is registered to my
account so it'll show up like I'll be
the owner of any projects that get
created or tasks but I want our project
manager to actually have access to that
and be able to have do whatever she
wants with it
so I need her ID and I need to put that
in so you'll see when I when I go to
send this this first request to test it
out you won't be able to see her ID but
because it's in the as an environment
variable but you'll see where I need to
have that ID in there so for the first
step we're just gonna try to send
something I'm not even gonna try to act
cool in the real data I'm just gonna
send something just to make sure that
it's working and then after that we can
try to send real data from a form and we
can also send the files so that'll be
tricky I'm not sure if we'll have enough
time to get to that because we have to
wait for a return from the API and
that'll give us the ID of the project
and then we use that to attach the files
to it
okay well Sebastian says he's trying to
sink his Fork with the repo but when I
commit it keeps failing tests managed to
bypass the test and push but still okay
is anybody else having issues like that
if you are let me know all yeah I don't
know I mean maybe send me send me a
screenshot if there's if there's any
messages when you fail the tests or
anything and maybe I'll have to talk to
maybe I have to talk to Kevin about it
as well because he's been setting up the
test and I've been trying to learn as
much as I can from what he's doing but
he'd probably know better than I would
since he set the tests up okay Patrick
says it's the timeouts
okay okay good to know
well maybe then okay maybe I'll have to
check those out then okay cool
alright ok let me get some code let me
do at least one Pomodoro cycle and then
I'll go back to the chat and and then
I'll answer all the questions and
everything ok so let me reset alright so
all I'm doing now is I'm gonna send a
post request to the API so I just need
to put in everything necessary for that
request to go through so let me see I
have okay so on my other screen I have
the current request that I'm sending
from the live version of this with Ajax
and I'm not gonna put it on my screen
because it has the the keys and
everything in it you know just in plain
text so I'm just gonna actually gonna
have to type it up because I don't I
don't want to copy over the keys so
let's see for the body I don't I guess I
don't really need to put it put anything
right now actually maybe I maybe I will
I might have to do this in a particular
in a particular way okay so let's try
so a lot of this stuff if you're
watching and you're kind of not familiar
with doing things like this a lot of
this is not going to be necessary every
time you make an API call to somewhere
it's just this particular API requires
things to be in this format just don't
want to don't want to mislead anybody to
think you have to have all of this to do
a post
okay so this way this description is
this is where our form data is gonna
actually go which for now we're just
going to test it with just a string oops
okay now this is where we're gonna need
to put the ID and it needs to be
it's a weird format so it needs to be an
array actually lets you know we're gonna
do this I think I'm gonna use a a
template literal yeah this I had trouble
with this when I first when I was trying
to get this to work before so this is
gonna look really weird but this is what
ended up working for me so hopefully we
can maybe clean it up a bit but for now
just I I realized that this is gonna be
weird
actually maybe I can get I think I might
be able to get rid of those first ones
okay
okay when I'd say processed end that's
gonna let me access whatever variables I
have saved in that dot end file so
always you know it has to be processed
and and then after that it's whatever
name I wanted to give it so I don't
remember what name I gave this so I need
to check what was it right sure okay so
this is gonna be the ID the user ID of
the person that I want to share this
project with and then we're also have
projects
and we're gonna create the project with
so almost done with this this is
probably gonna be like the most tedious
boring part of this almost done
okay I think I'm done and that's all I
need for now at least in this part okay
everything else is gonna make a little
bit more sense but this was like I said
that unique to the right API so anyway
one of these things in a very specific
way so this is what ended up working so
hopefully I copied that over correctly I
need to add headers so let's say we have
the URL method Oddie yeah I need headers
and then our API key is gonna go into
the headers so let's see we just need it
there
station
and if you're not sure what's going on
with these dollar signs I'm not using
jQuery this is template literal syntax
so when I use these little back ticks
it's a string just like if I was using
you know quotation marks but then within
the string I can do dollar sign curly
bracket and then I can put JavaScript
within there okay so instead of adding a
lot of plus science and concatenating
everything we can do it like that and
for this one I'm gonna need my last oops
I forgot this I'm sure you all saw that
I'm not even gonna look at the live chat
right now because I'm sure it's full of
people saying that I forgot it okay and
here's where API key goes okay let me do
one last check to make sure I got
everything I think that said think
that's all that I this is all I was
sending in the other version of this so
and it's working there all right so
let's save that and for now it has
everything I don't really have to pass
anything in here so let's just have it
run
when we submit something so let's see so
do it down here below where we're doing
emails
so let's do
and I remember what I named this Center
bike
and
I guess I'm not gonna pass yeah I don't
really need any data in there right now
let's see so let's see what happens
and I think I have everything on my
other screen right now let me find it
I'm not sure where there it is a lot of
stuff okay
it's refresh to clear some of this I
don't really need anything in here so
let's submit and I'm gonna check I have
my the project management system open on
my other screen and I'm not gonna be
able to show it because I'm pretty sure
that my bosses would not want me showing
all of our projects in the comments on
all of our projects on the screen so I'm
just gonna verify on the other screen
that this sent and let's see what would
no I guys see what would I name this it
would have came out as okay test
so it could probably
alright I'm not I don't think it worked
occasionally it does take a minute for
this to show up so I'll check one more
time okay yes I don't think it worked
yeah Patrick I know I'm hitting 9,000
and the problem was just if you remember
I have that Corsair on three thousand
and I never I never fixed that I
actually I checked into the plugin that
someone I can't remember who was with
someone had recommended a plugin for
Chrome to get rid of the Korres error
stuff I checked it out and it looked
like for some people it worked great and
for other people it it messed things up
like YouTube wouldn't work for them or
all kind of different services wouldn't
work for them and since I'm running
YouTube to do the stream while I'm doing
this I didn't want to add the plug-in so
what I think I'm gonna do maybe is if I
need to test it I'll just test it on
9,000 or I guess I could do 3,000 on
Firefox since it works there but I
shouldn't need I mean as soon as we have
this working I shouldn't really need to
test it out anymore so it really won't
be a big deal I can just run everything
off of 3000 but for now it just seemed
like just easier just to do it you know
for the few times that we'll need to
test it I mean probably only be working
with this another day or two and then
we'll just move on to styling everything
and adding in the the proper content
okay so let me actually let me see if I
have anything in the console
when I try to do this
okay let me see
all right let's see what response we're
getting
okay I forgot to mention I do have the
Instagram stream going as well and if
you are watching right now on Instagram
you want to see the code check out the
free code camp YouTube channel and then
you can see what's going on on my screen
I'm just copying over some of what's in
the the documentation for node fetch
okay
let's give it a shot
okay so I didn't let me bring this over
so I can see what I'm seeing here
so I never sorry I didn't realize that I
kept looking over to check the the
console to see what was happening so our
parameter title is required and it's an
invalid invalid parameter so let's check
it out so we have title and it's telling
me test is invalid
let's see what I'm currently sending
currently I'm just sending a string it's
an email address as the title
okay
actually let me check did I bring over
the documentation I think I pulled it
back to the other screen let's see okay
on the in the documentation it does say
that it needs a title but the title can
be a string and that's that's what we're
sending right now
and it's irresponsible
create photo that's what I want okay
it's still--it's tostring so this is an
example formatted poorly of what I would
I actually need to send
hmm
yeah they're even using Texas potato so
what am I doing wrong like something
wrong
oh cool Patrick says Reich is free for
up to five users so if anyone really
wanted to try out Reich and getting get
an API key I guess you could I'm not
sure if the API is available for the
free version or not
hopefully it is alright so I'm I'm
really not sure what the problem is let
me bring alright I'm gonna show you all
what the settings are that I'm currently
sending
hmm
yeah let me I'm gonna need to clean it
up a bit
meaning take out all the stuff that the
API keys and then all I'll show you
okay
okay let me show you
all right so here's using Ajax these are
my settings that are working anywhere
that is you see that it's blank
that's where was something that's now an
environment variable so just assume that
I did have the right thing in there so
this is the area right right here where
we're having trouble and you know this
variable for email was just a string
with someone's email address in it so
you can see I've attempted to replicate
everything well pretty much everything I
left out a few things just wanted to see
if it worked without it yeah but see
basically what I'm wondering about is if
I'm simply missing something between the
difference between using Ajax to send
this and using fetch to send this if I'm
missing something or formatting it wrong
although based on the error it does seem
like I mean let's show this error again
as well I mean it seems like it's
hitting the API in because we're getting
this description back of title is
required and it's invalid so so anyway
I'm basically just not really sure what
to do from here so I'm going to give you
all just a minute to check that out see
if you have any ideas
now now that this is happening I
remember it's all coming back to me now
I remember working with this API before
and having a lot of trial and error of
trying to get this to work
I mean you know the biggest difference
that I see and I'm not really sure I
would make a difference maybe it
wouldn't at all is I'm using double
quotes everywhere over here and single
quotes here and the only reason I even
thought of that is I know at least in
JSON you have to use double quotes is it
possible that that's my issue
okay so wolf says maybe you need to
escape the quotes on title
yes you see
I don't know
we sense something is like easy
yes I'm making that is easy to read
objects in json stringify
okay so Patrick says try making those
easy-to-read objects and then
json.stringify them all right so base so
Patrick are you saying this part should
then be an object that's stringify and
then I just pass it in obviously in the
same spot
or just this part then yeah I think is
you're talking about just this part okay
all right cool thank you
all right so let's make
okay so temporarily we're gonna do this
okay okay Gavin says that it's
recommended to stringify the body so
okay so let's try that
I'm sure you'll let me know if I did
this wrong but we'll give it a try and
actually this will probably be our last
try whether or not it works because my
timer is definitely gone up a few
minutes ago and I want to make sure that
I get to your questions at least as many
as I can before my meeting
same thing alright let's see
all right now I said that was gonna be
it I'm not gonna try anything else okay
Patrick says now get rid of the template
literals they need to remove the quotes
okay let me see what time is it
yeah let me answer some questions and
I'll work on this more later on so
actually so Gavin asks is the API
expecting the title to be an email no I
I don't think so
I think it could be well based on the
documentation so we had it up on a
screen would I do with it
so based on the documentation it's just
a string so the only it just can't be
empty but we just need a string so I
mean according to that I mean that's
that would work so I mean these are the
parameters that we need
and we have so basically this is we just
need title really all this other stuff
we don't even need yet just to test it
all right well I'll have to try either
later on today or tomorrow morning I'll
try out just all kind of different stuff
and see what works that's what I had to
to the last time don't have quotes on
the frames
okay let me MFC I'm gonna copy your the
link that you posted in there and I'm
gonna check that out after my meeting
probably not after I'll private leave
right after my meeting so off to work on
this tomorrow morning okay remove the
quotes or let me try this one thing then
actually this this might be the problem
and this night this will fix the problem
maybe it makes sense I probably don't
have to refresh this but I'm just like
when I I was doing it before to clear
out the fields but now I'm not even
using
to make sure that the sexy running okay
it is
yeah and we're still not shoot
yeah all right one more
we'll try double quotes just see it's
possible it's possible they're looking
for double quotes yeah yeah maybe maybe
I kind of think now that it's something
like that maybe I'm not yeah I'll check
it out and the problem at least I've
seen with the right KPI the only thing I
don't like about it is it doesn't seem
that there's that many people using it
because I can't find a lot at least when
I worked with it before I couldn't find
a lot like on Stack Overflow about it so
I'll try to look it up tomorrow morning
and see if somebody has had similar
issues but I'm not really hopeful that
I'll find something so I don't know what
it is if it's just not a popular system
or people just don't use the API I'm not
sure but I'm gonna check out the the
links and I'm gonna try out to do I know
there are other suggestions and things
in the live chat so I'm gonna check all
that out and let me go through now and
just see what questions if you have any
questions for me I put them in the live
chat now probably can only take about
ten minutes of questions today yeah okay
well I just saw wolf that's exactly what
I was thinking
wolf says it sounds like it's not
receiving the data section at all now
yeah that was my last thought after we
after we tried the double quote so I
thought maybe it's just not getting this
because it yeah so it's possible that's
I don't know that's what I'm gonna check
into is is it getting this at all and if
not
why not okay so I'm gonna scroll back up
see if I missed any questions and this
feels so rush since I've been doing like
two hour-long shows lately but this is
actually longer than I originally was
doing half hour streams now thinking
about it I'm like how did I get anything
done in a half an hour but when I
started sometimes there is maybe like
nobody watching and just one person so
the question answer sessions were a lot
shorter
how many says demo deployment on Heroku
might help a newcomer like me oh yeah
actually could I deploy this yeah maybe
I could try to deploy this I think you
can deploy create react app stuff on
github pages that would probably be the
easiest yeah off to think about that oh
also I didn't fire up the the anger hog
server today and that was actually on
purpose so I was thinking and correct me
if I'm wrong if I ran this on and rock
and someone tried to use the file
uploader they could potentially upload
files to my local machine correct so if
that's correct
and especially since we don't have any
type of security setup to like check the
file types or anything then I'm probably
not gonna run and rock while we're
working on this and then once we get it
working I'll just disable it and then
run and Rock and work on the rest of the
site
Shawn says keep the videos please I'm
catching up awesome
yeah I'll definitely definitely keep
doing the videos and they'll they'll be
available on free code camps Channel
okay Sebastian I saw that you just now
that you shared a link to the photo
I'm guessing of the era errors that
you're giving so I'll check that out and
try to get it all let's try to get that
working with the test so too bad I think
it doesn't seem like Kevin is watching
today so I was hoping to be able to ask
him about it
Peter says thank you so much for what
you're doing you're welcome thanks for
watching
okay going through almost to the bottom
there's actually not very many questions
okay Gavin I see your comment now about
using curl just to check to see that the
API works so the API is working so I
have it I have it running basically this
but in the form of I'm using Ajax
instead of fetch so I have that running
on the live version of this site and it
works so I know the API works I get we
get submissions on it everyday so that's
that's definitely working
Matthew s what is he doing exactly
Patrick had a good answer basically I'm
trying to integrate with the project
management API yeah that's that is what
I'm trying to do the the project
management system is called Reich
okay Evan says you could try double
quotes on the params maybe because I had
that in the settings on the right yeah
actually that I did have that in the
setting so yeah I'll have to try that
next
okay so wolf says what if it has to be
something like this and let me show you
all I'm gonna copy and paste this over
so we'll saying what about something
like that so body and then data json
stringify test body yeah maybe I'm gonna
see how if this was in a few actually
maybe that'll work
yeah off to try that
eatery 33 says love the stream and all
that FCC free code camp does I'll be
able to create our own streams / videos
about free code camp as well you can
certainly do it on your own channel if
you wanted to be able to stream on free
code camps channel or do videos then I
would get in touch with Quincy so Quincy
is at free code camp on Twitter he runs
that Twitter or I'm sure you can get on
the free code camp website there's a
page where you can get contact info for
all the different people that are in
charge of various things I'm in charge
of nothing except my own stream so I
can't give any permission to anyone to
do videos but you can certainly ask
about it and see if if that's a
possibility
okay Gavin says I think I'll try to
follow along with you using my company's
project management JIRA I have to start
from day one though yeah that's cool I'd
love to hear how that goes so keep keep
me up to date on how everything is going
for you Gavin
yeah there's a lot to catch up on once
we get into a project I always notice
that the view count so day one of a
project always has like by far the most
views and like every day after that it
seems like it drops a little bit
occasionally depending on what I'm
working on I guess it will fluctuate but
the the farther I get in like less and
less people make it that far to catch up
with everything so like I think day one
for this project has like over twelve
thousand views now and then the last one
we did on Friday has maybe like twelve
hundred views so it's I guess try to get
through I know who is it I don't know if
Bill's still in here but bills will
watch sometimes on like four times speed
you're able to watch it on it's just
crazy I wonder how I sound on four times
speed
okay Patrick says json.stringify is
handling making valid JSON with double
quote so it shouldn't matter what I'm
doing with the quotes because it should
be formatted correctly
okay cool good idea Gavin let me just
write this in here now so I don't forget
[Music]
actually I'm just I won't have time I
got to go to my meeting in like two
minutes so I'm gonna paste that right
here so that I don't forget and I'll
leave this up on my screen when I leave
today so when I log in when I come to
work tomorrow and I turn I never really
turned off my computer but when I when I
log in and this shows up then I will
remember and I was try it out
all right let's see okay wolf says the
two-hour length on the video is somewhat
intimidating this is the first time I'm
watching oh welcome thanks for watching
yeah I know the length is is
intimidating I had I don't know at
various times I try to get it short to
be shorter but it seems like we'll be
working on something and I just want to
get it done so we'll keep going or even
if I get something the coding portion
done you're relatively you know kind of
on time then I'll have a lot of
questions so if I really wanted I'm not
really that worried about it if I wanted
to be more disciplined I guess I would
just cut it off at a certain time and
even if I didn't get to all the
questions and I may have to do that you
know if there's enough people watching
and asking questions at some point I'll
just have to cut it off because I you
know I wouldn't be able to answer to be
hours and hours so we'll see I do I
think I definitely want to start getting
it back down towards the one hour and
not go over two hours anymore so anyway
but I'll take that in consideration
because I've gotten similar comments
about the length it's just it it's just
really long
okay let's see
hey Kevin's here how's the corn
okay Wolf Wolf says I think it's
excellent that they are that long just
think it has something to do with your
view counts yeah yeah you're right all
right
so I yeah I have two minutes and so on
meeting starts so I definitely have to
go if you do have any questions just
send them to me on Twitter and put them
in the comments to the video I'll try to
get to them as soon as I can thank you
so much for watching today and for
helping me out sorry we couldn't
actually get anything accomplished but
hopefully I can get it all sorted out
tomorrow morning and then show you how I
got it to work for tomorrow's video I
think two o'clock tomorrow will work so
I will see you then have a great day